hello everyone and welcome to what i
thought was going to be the video of the
final round of the 2021 singfield cup uh
in a game between maximo sheila grav and
chakra mamidarov but instead i decided
to show this one maxim won the
tournament but his last round game
against mamadyarov was uh well it wasn't
the snooze fest but it was it was a line
uh that is very often used amongst grand
masters to to achieve quick draw so i'm
gonna show it real quickly we're just
gonna fly through the moves and then
we're gonna show the actual game that
this video is about so in the game that
i'm showing mommy there i've had the
white pieces against maxine and this is
a game from the final round of the scene
field cup so d4 uh we have knight to f6
so uh just a normal groomfield defense
we have captures captures e4 nothing out
of the ordinary here so just a normal
opening
i'm flying through the moves because
we've already shown this game on the
channel and i decided never to show it
again uh you know by analyzing moves but
i'm going to show it to you uh just for
the sake of uh those who still have not
seen this drawing mechanism knight to c5
bishop here and now uh on move uh 19
black attacks the white queen on e1 but
uh we have bishop catras on d4 so here
mamidaro gives up the queen maxime
captures it and now mamidarov gains a
perpetual here with rook to g7 check uh
king has to move we're gonna move rook
to d7 again opening up a discovery here
so the
rook from d8 cannot capture our bishop
and here we have a repetition and he was
in this position on move 25 that uh
mamidarov and the maxim agreed to a draw
uh now that being said uh let's check
out the actual game and the game in
question is maxine vashilogra versus sam
shankland and this is actually a game
from round three uh of the uh 2021
singing field cup so let's check it out
with e4 uh by maxine uh e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 going for
the for the italian game we have bishop
to c5
and now maxime unfortunately did not go
for the absolute best move here he
played c3 goes for the main line of the
joko piano
knight to f6 and d3 now we have d6
castles and a6
we have a4 and h6 so this has all been
played before nothing um uh weird
happening here we have rook to e1 and
the bishop back to a7 uh we have knight
beat to d2 and now uh usually people
just castle here uh but uh shanklin goes
bishop to e6 and this was played only
once so far so he's trying uh a very
very uh
sneaky variation against maxime so let's
see what he had in mind bishop captures
f captures and knight to f1 now and here
there is one game that i've mentioned
where castles was played but shanklin
plays a5 and it is now adds of move 11
that we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how maxine continues here
knights the g3 uh just a natural
development of the knight queen d7 now
uh leaving the option of black the
castle king side and queen side bishop
to e3 countering black's dark square
bishop on a7 and here shankland trades
we have captures captures and the g5 and
now we see what shanklin's idea was he
wants to attack on the king side so
naturally he will probably castle
queenside and what's the best way to
react when someone attacks you on the
king's side well of course you counter
attack in the center especially if the
king is still in the center of the board
uh so d4 by maxime uh and now we have
castles by shankland we have d5
attacking the knight and the e6 pawn
captures captures and knight to e7 now
so the pawn is now attacked twice and
maximum of course will defend it we have
c4
and now knight to g4 attacking the rook
and e3 and the maxim shifts it over to
b3 rook to b3 and now he does have some
ideas here of how he wants to attack the
queen side the the a51 is not defended
so this will be his plan we have rook d
to f8 shifting the rook over to the file
and now there are some ideas of knight
captures on f2 king captures and then
we're gonna attack the knight since uh
the king will be on the same file as the
rook so here queen to e1 uh defending
the the f2 pawn with the queen and also
attacking the a5 pawn so here b6
shanklin needs to defend his a5 pawn and
now rook to b5 and now maxine will just
play b4 bust open the position here and
win the game if uh of course shankland
doesn't do anything so he goes for it
knight captures on f2 and now of course
we're not going to capture with the king
we're going to capture with the queen
that was the plan and now g4 the knight
seemingly cannot move as black would
capture the white queen but that's only
seemingly because knight captures on e5
was played now the rook is attacking the
white queen but the knight is also
attacking the black queen and here if
you just capture the knight uh white's
gonna move the queen and the white white
will be better here uh still the same
ideas apply c5 will just you know
completely destroy the position also b4
is still in the game so not much for for
black to hope for here so instead after
knight captures on e5 we have queen
captures on b5 now eliminating the white
rook here uh and a captures on b5 we
have rook captures on f2 king captures
and have to end only now recapturing the
knight with the d captures on e5 king to
e3 and now uh as a white is ready to to
claim the file for himself black of
course will not allow this rook to f8
and we have this uh position where the
material is completely equal maxine has
uh a double b pawn but he has two pawn
islands uh shanklin has three and maksim
has a bit of a more active king and here
we have rook to f1
he says the the rooks must come off the
board and it's a very natural decision
because white rook is doing absolutely
nothing and uh
well aside from controlling the f file
there really isn't another job for the
rook to be doing now so rook to f1 you
have to counter black's rook and now
black just trades we have captures
captures and now knight to f5 with check
uh king to d3 uh you could also go king
to e4 but then we just repeat knight to
d6 check and it's a really uh well not
not something you want to go for knight
captures on c4 loses this and you know
uh black will just be be better here so
instead after knight to f5 check we have
king to d3 you are always safe when you
put your king uh
when you put a one square in between
your king and your opponent's knight
we have king to d7 now shankler also
starts bringing the king into the game
knight to d2 now we have knight to d6 uh
and now comes knight to e4 and here is
the
position that really really uh
well gives us a lot of knowledge about
chess in general uh here you have to
play a knight to e8 but that's uh
that's a very uh
well
that that's a move that uh you you have
to know you have to play otherwise you
don't play it uh because here if you
play what was played in the game then uh
the the game is just lost so here knight
to e8 you have to control uh df6 square
and there will be no knight to f6 check
followed by knight captures on g4 now
you're just controlling this f6 square
and you can see that the pawns are doing
a very nice job of keeping the white
king away from you know reaching any
anything in in black's half of the board
so you don't really have any any good
moves here if you go knight to f2 we can
simply defend it with knight to f6 so
not much for you to do there
but instead king the e7 was played and
now well he
he allows the maxim a very very
interesting idea so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find this idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on successfully
solving the first pause the video moment
as there will be at least another one
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight captures and
d6 that's what we
needed to see and that's the title of
the video uh
you know king and pawn really is is
everything so here c captures on d6 and
now king to e4 uh and there is no wait
uh for black to keep equality here now
you have to prevent king to f5 if king
to f5 is just game over so king to f6 is
your only move uh and now b3 maxine just
wastes a move here uh prevents uh a4 by
black and now you you either move the
king or you have to play something with
with the pawns if h5 we're just gonna
play g3 and again you have to play king
to g6 and our next move is the same so
instead after this
b3 move we have king to g6 right away by
shankland uh but now feel free to pause
the video for the second time and find
it the only winning move for white while
i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
black king is too far away from the from
the white pawns uh that are soon to be
past pawns and for those who just want
to enjoy the show uh it is of course c5
and this move ensures that we either get
a pass pawn by capturing uh by pushing
uh well really depends on what black
plays but uh all you know if black
captures uh with either pawn then we're
just gonna get another pass pawn that is
very close to queening and capturing
with the b pawn makes little sense
because after b6 uh the king is too far
away he's outside the the square of the
pawn uh and if you try something like c
for captures and a4 we're very much uh
well we're a lot faster and we're gonna
be able to prevent the black queen
we can deliver check then play some like
queen a3 guard the queening square and
that's it so instead after c5 d captures
and c5 makes makes much more sense this
is what shanklin played uh but now d6 we
have king to f7 okay the king's side is
now inside the square of the pawn
but now maxine uh plays a really really
cool move he doesn't capture on e5
although they're capturing an e5 wins
the game just the same yeah i'm just
going to show it uh
for example a4 black wants to create a
pass pawn of his own captors in c4
d7 king to e7 and now king to d4 we're
going to capture here you're going to
capture here in this position is now
winning for white but maxime chooses a
different line that allows black to
preserve his uh past pawn but is also
hopeless for him so here king to d5 by
maxine uh we have e4 king to c6 with e3
now comes d7 e2 a d8 queen and e1 queen
so both players get a queen into the
game but now king captures on b6 and uh
well maxime has another beautiful past b
pawn now he's just gonna move the king
and promote the spawn uh to another
queen so here we have queen to e6 check
king to a7 and now c4 black also creates
another pass pawn but it doesn't help
him all that much b captures with a4 uh
b6 with a3 b7 and now a2 and now of
course you don't want to bring a queen
into the game uh if you do that uh black
just brings his own queen into the game
and now uh well this comes with check
and you're just dead lost king to b7
we're going to deliver check and after
the king moves we're going to have this
beautiful checkmate with uh the the four
queens surrounding the white king so
after a2 we have queen to c7 check first
by maxine king the g6 and now just uh
well there's only one winning move here
for white but i'm not gonna ask you to
pause the video because it's a really
easy one to find since you have to stop
the pawn from being promoted that of
course the movie is queen to a5 and
after that there's really nothing for
shanklin to do here there are no checks
uh you could deliver one check queen to
e3 check but after we move the king
there is no way to continue the game if
queen a8 check we just bring our queen
into the game and that's it we blocked
check easily winning
so uh after this um uh after this uh
really awesome queen to a5 move uh it
was in this position that sam shanklin
resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for maxine vashilograph in round
three uh of the 2021 singfield cup so i
hope you don't mind that i've shown this
game instead of the game from the last
run but
even though i okay i did show it i just
didn't analyze it but the most of you
know about uh this drawing mechanism so
it was only you know quickly went
through it for those of you who still
haven't seen it uh but yeah now if you
guys are interested about the standings
these are the standings after the final
round so maxima maxine vashilograv wins
it
and
well followed by fabiano caruana wesley
so and linear dominguez and it was a it
was a pretty pretty crazy fight um
okay here something's different here we
only have the the grand chester points
but uh all in all fabi uh uh um and
maxime ended by uh winning the
tournament uh with a half a point lead
and a la you know there were three
people following him uh i think uh
wesley was on six fabio was on six and
let me just quickly check uh so i don't
uh
i'll tell you yeah okay and the
dominguez of course and uh uh fabi uh
fabi faced uh
uh sorry let me just check really
quickly yeah fabi faced richard rapport
in the final round and he only got a
draw he couldn't force a win against
rapport uh so uh naturally he ended the
the the the tournament half point behind
maxima sherlock
and wesley faced linear dominguez in the
final round and uh well as the two of
them drew the game uh they they finished
with five and a half points uh we have
in fifth place richard rapper with four
and a half jeffree xiong with four
mamidarov with four shankland with four
peter swiller with three and a half and
dario schwitz with two and a half points
so that's it for for the uh 2021 uh
sinful couple hope you guys enjoyed it
uh like i said if as we've been covering
the morphe saga for quite a while now
and i've missed a lot of things that
were happening so if you have any
favorites of your own that occurred you
know in in in a serious tournament in
online play doesn't really matter just
use hashtag suggestion in the comments
or send me an email and i will check out
your suggestion uh so that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it really awesome
stuff by maxine uh uh wesley is the
wesley so is the uh well overall winner
of the grand chester 2021 uh and he
uh won it by by you know it wasn't uh it
wasn't even close so congratulations to
wesley so as well uh but yeah i hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
meredith
and alain goid for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of whatever else
is happening in the chess world checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
that's that's it for now uh thank y'all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day